[Music]  [Applause]  the mission of the ftth council europe  is to promote fiber networks as  essential infrastructure for the  competitiveness and prosperity of europe  for ukraine today connectivity is vital  a month ago we invited at the ftth  conference andrei nabok from the  ministry of digital transformation and  eureka mart ceo at ukraine telecom their  keynote speeches describe the impact of  the war and the needs on the ground  reaching the hearts  and the minds of the three thousand  professionals  present at the event  we also partnered with an ngo raising  funds to aid ukrainian people  we have been encouraging and helping our  members especially those vendors of  fiber equipment  to bring material support to ukrainian  operators  and we welcome and actively support the  initiative from the european commission  to coordinate and reinforce this effort  essential for the resilience of ukraine  telecom infrastructures